I have been waiting for you I never
thought I'd get to eat you oh oh you are
spicy mother come ma I'm doctor boy you
see you've met our Hospital support duck
cheetah already yeah yeah yeah I'm sorry
dude I have a sandwich here's a sandwich
yes sandwich I had a turkey and Swiss
and it was right here honestly I think
your dog ate my sandwich
okay cheetah did not eat your sandwich
but we did detect some heart murmur so
we're gonna have to run a couple look
her she's freakin laughing at me like
I'm some idiot that dog ate my sandwich
okay how dare you she and I have been
working in this hospital for years she
would never do something like that
besides she specifically eats these
vegan dog treats frigging ha ha ha ha
that is rich you're telling me that if I
do a piece of steak and for that dog she
wasn't scarf it up you owe me a sandwich
ok will you shut up about the sandwich
already cookies and Swiss spicy mustard
weren't you right none of us though if
there was a sandwich you've been in a
coma for a year so it wouldn't be edible
oh well look who's a doctor up
sandwiches now I'm a doctor of hearts
and yours is about to explode you moron
Oh give me this food no she needs my
food I'm gonna need her at first
watch that
okay what are you trying to prove
they're gonna have a heart attack tit
for tat baby
[Music]
hey Doc quick question how old is too
old for a sandwich
you